one thing I thought was effective was
the way that Chris I think on the first
the first day I attended and watched you
kind of laid out a sort of more
theoretical framework you know about
storytelling and that sort of thing and
I think that was nice because it for me
it's you know I think it's effective and
I'm just one kind of learner but to sort
of have a sort of theory laid out first
and then practice later you know sorry I
got the big idea of the Y and then it
felt to me like the course dove into
some of the details of how you know this
was like a theory practice kind of
structure which I which work you know
would have been quite useful to me how
to take in the whole course you know
yeah one of the big one of the big
challenges I think with any kind of
media course or you know film video is
that that the technical stuff is so
overwhelming potentially people who are
new you know that there's such a big
learning curve that you know you can get
lost in those details really fast and
you go oh my god you know as you say
I'll never learn final cut why does
everything I shoot suck oh this is
terrible i'm a failure and if you kind
of go well those aren't really the
learning objectives which are you very
clearly articulated then it's like kind
of a big unclench it's like okay what
I'm really learning here is to be a
communicator be a storyteller carry
myself understand this medium and maybe
maybe someday I'll be a terrific editor
or maybe I won't but either way maybe
you'll plug into the process and some
other it some other way exactly yeah but
you have to understand the whole process
right I remember when I first proposed
like because you were like what do you
want me to do because i was just like
can you be involved in this and how and
it was sort of like well maybe you could
cover the actual basics of shooting and
everything being said something like
they seem like very technical things and
i was like oh shoot like this is
terrible i'm doing the thing that i tell
people not to do so we made a very
conscious decision to take all those
technical elements like we did not teach
how to edit on soft on final cut or
anything
instead mit has free window licensing
and honestly like their videos teach it
better than I do like I I don't know
final cut well enough to teach it but
not all the students used it so we said
for all like the technical learning
stuff it was all on like digital blended
learning mm-hmm flipped classroom yeah
thank you and class time was really
about teaching big picture stuff and
then workshopping specific examples and
specific things they came up with yeah
cuz time is limited and it's so daunting
I mean to become a director on-camera
host writer-editor camera person all in
a few weeks I mean it's just not going
to happen this is the expectation that
they come out with a notion of
storytelling I think would be sufficient
yeah yeah it really ended up being a
class on pre-production it was like two
weeks of intense scripting and planning
yeah um and the rest just sort of
happened to him the last couple days
they just have to figure out yeah that's
that's great I mean your technical
execution gets pushed to the margin and
the more creative you know stuff takes
precedence yeah I mean it's a different
class like I there were a couple people
who dropped because they came in
thinking like this is going to be a
class on how to make a video and it's
not exactly about that mm-hmm and
because there are other classes like
that that already exist on campus so
there's no reason for us to redo that
and you learn that stuff by like
shooting your own stuff yeah yeah yeah
but like if someone's going to watch
this class on it open courseware for
instance they're not necessarily going
to pick up the practical skills that
they might be expecting to like yeah
yeah but like a teacher who might be
watching this might be like how do I
teach a video production class and I'm
not sure this is necessarily exactly
that sorry
oops yeah but it is hopefully maybe a
conceptual framework that you could then
plug in production modules into I mean
yeah for a larger course yeah it was so
short yeah I guess friend yeah what can
you do Claire can you accomplish in that
time really yeah I was impressed by how
ambitious it was he was very ambitious i
thought yeah yeah yeah